you're watching film courage yeah
hello there Karen Gordon will encourage
the radio show here with the wonderful
John Paul rice producer of one hour
fantasy girl and the magic stone with no
restrictions entertainment so as most
people probably are aware of the Old
Spice video campaign has kind of taken
the nation and probably the world by
storm and it's an ingenious way to build
an audience how are you building an
audience for your work what works what
doesn't what's a waste of time when you
cut loose I think the most important
part is the emotional connection that
audience can quickly have with something
and in evidence in the Old Spice it's
not just the gimmick or trickery behind
it but is having a character that you
really like I mean there's there's women
that love this guy and there's men that
want to be this guy and he's confident
and he's creative and kind of has the
charm and that flare so that I think
really aside from the visual aesthetics
of what's going on or the connection of
who you want to be and how do you feel
and relate to the message of what that
person is projecting so I think one of
the most effective ways for filmmakers
to build an audience is to get quips
even a rough edit clips they're not
necessarily the finished product but get
those out there and start staggering
them create different types of media
where you really put a face and a name
and a person on your cast so for example
you do the behind the scenes stuff could
even come after the film is done where
you do cast and crew interviews really
just it's not just so that you can
create all these different videos but
with people
you relate to and he go I like these
people the underlying thing is I like
these people and they're doing something
if I'm not a filmmaker and not into the
film industry but I'm participant in
this this form of art that I'm relating
the script going I like who they are and
I like what they're doing and they're
doing something cool that's different
and new I think that's a very very
strong way to reach people I've seen it
and what we did with one our fantasy bro
we did exactly that and I proved itself
not just in sales that people starting
to talk more about it it gave people
options so that we're not just watching
the trailer or a clip and now we're
talking with other people and seeing who
they are as people in their professional
life but also in a personal way
delivered in a very personal emotional
way I think some of the things that are
if you say throw aways or waste of time
I think that if you don't have the
content behind it that any it doesn't
matter what platform you're on or what
you know gimmicks you created if it's
and I'm not saying calling this but
transmedia for example is used as a ploy
to get people in but not really in a
thoughtful way what's one of the great
things I'm seeing right now and this is
this is with the tilt movie the
fundraising they've created the tilt
town and they're their new stories that
keep emerging from that and I think it's
a really smart way for people to stay
engaged in this process while their
funding the film to play around in this
world and kind of get into the movie a
little bit more it's almost like a
further extension of what the story will
end up being and and it builds as an
excitement for how it will turn out I
think those are really smart and they
don't cost a lot of money sister time to
really do something unique
I think that you know trying to reach
out other people who are not mutually
invested in what you're doing is a waste
of time I think that no right now the
main focus for people to try to connect
with an audience is going directly to
them rather than to try to reach up to
an establishment that already has its
own concerns financially and with
content to try to get them to pay
attention to you that really doesn't
directly benefit them and that's across
the board I think that you have to go
out and find your Oprah's your
influencers the people that are your
biggest champions and those people could
even be fans they don't have to be these
high already established authority
figures but really getting your audience
involved asking for people who've seen
your movie to give a review get them to
talk to you about other movies and and
really exchange and share ideas I think
that's the foundation of a relationship
when you don't have all this money and
its marketing in this media behind you
is how do you create the excitement
starts with the content and then it's
how you're going to go forward and try
to connect with those people